I bind because it's kind of quiet that
dysphoria that I get I bind because it
makes me feel safer when I'm outside I
bind because I think I look a lot hotter
when I'm in a binder than when I'm not I
started binding about a year ago two
years maybe eight months ago six years I
first started binding when I was a
teenager in college almost five and a
half years I bind it straight
you kind of just wear it like a tank top
and you know it just totally finds your
chest I think I had like double D's and
I would put on the binder and it would
probably go down to sizes just because
it's so tight and it's like a suction
cup almost is just like holding
everything tightly together so this is
the one that I got during my freshman
year of college you can see it's very
very very stretched out and like see
through it I'm not sure how this whole
app it but it's there I like to be
androgynous so I feel like this helps me
to achieve that I don't know I was just
really uncomfortable in t-shirts and I
wear a lot of button shirts pretty open
about it because I complain about it a
lot I also have friends who are like in
the same situation where they also can't
like afford Top surgery
it allowed me to go out into public with
you know a shirt on and just be able to
seen as a guy because you know it was
before Top surgery if I didn't have my
binder I couldn't function I just
couldn't go out I couldn't have dinner
with friends I couldn't talk to family
because I wasn't the Renee that I the
whole Renee or as closest to the whole
Renee I could be without my binder with
me I've had this for you from with my
breast since they grew in I tried to use
like regular tape to like tape them
nails is like what's happening is a
little bit on my chest I have a lot of
fear of you know getting assaulted or
just being stared at in public cuz like
I definitely don't like to leave my
apartment without my binder even to go
to like the corner store to buy like a
cup of coffee and you put it on and it's
what you want and what you need it's the
most like you fork feeling you're like
yes I'm complete and seeing kind of a
silhouette that looks right instead of
these weird lumps in front of me they
tell you to bind correctly or it'll hurt
but I feel like binding just doesn't
feel good at all it was 77 degrees
yesterday in New York and I was just
sweat was pouring down my potty ah like
it feels really good to take it off when
people think about binding they might
think it's like very constricting
something that's painful why would you
want to do that to your body but it's
just a way to kind of connect our mind
to our body I didn't want to look like
or feel like I had breasts even though
binding does help give that apparent
appearance that they are gone it is a
strong reminder that they are there
sometimes you're gonna put that binder
on and it's not going to change anything
for you and it's okay to have those
moments there's not a lot of discussions
especially outside of the trans
community about binding and I think that
more people should talk about it and we
should be allowed to be more open about
it and feel more free having these
discussions
Wow